eiserne disziplin ordnung knallhartes
training und unmenschlich frühes
aufstehen ich möchte wissen ob ich die
härte und disziplin der navy seals an
den tag legen kann was passiert wenn ich
jene auf meinen alltag anwenden und so
lieber als wäre ich selbst teil der us
spezialeinheit der bröseln mit dieser
für extremsituation optimierten
mentalität alle probleme und aufgaben
unseres alltags ich werde weiterhin
sowohl am anfang und am ende des films
den navy seal fitness machen um
herauszufinden ob ich vor oder
wenigstens nach dieser woche bestehen
würde aber vielleicht guckt mich dieser
lebensstil bereits wieder unsanft aus
bevor ich überhaupt an ein ende denken
darf
dieses video wieder unterstützt von
atletic greens wie lebt ein navy seal
unsere recherchen zum alltag der
us-spezialeinheit stellen sich als
schwierig heraus klar ist die navy seals
sind die militär spezialeinheit
schlechthin zu sehen zu luft zu land sie
kommen immer dann zum einsatz wenn es
maximal ernst wird man erinnert sich zum
beispiel an der tötung osama bin ladens
in 2011 ich möchte mit diesem video
weder gewalt noch militär generell und
vor allem das us militär im speziellen
keineswegs verherrlichen quasi als
nebenprodukt der zu recht umstrittenen
suche und ausbildung der besten killer
entstand eine kultur aus disziplin
ordnung und körperlichen extremst
leistungen mit dem motto die only the
day yesterday der einzige leichte tag
war gestern und alleine dafür
interessiere ich mich und ausschließlich
davon handelt dieses video von der
bezwingung des eigenen geistes im
internet kursieren verschiedene gerüchte
darüber was nein wir sehen uns von
morgens bis abends alles zu machen aber
wir haben einfach die wahrheit gefunden
und zwar nicht in irgendwelchen
reißerischen dokus oder filmen oder
magazin sondern einfach auf der
offiziellen webseite ein detaillierter
tagesablauf inklusive morgen routine
ernährung training und und bis 35 kann
geschlafen werden dann gibt es aber den
fruchtsaft der energie bringt zum
aufwachen der stunde später 36 bis 38
nicht einmal zwei stunden lang harter
sport direkt im anschluss frühstück und
anfang an von 30 bis 110 zu unterricht
oder unterweisungen dann von 10 bis 12
uhr gibt es arbeiten an der ausrüstung
oder sonstige sachen um 11 wieder den
snack und direkt zwei stimmen danach
gibt es schon mittagessen das krasseste
des nachmittags ab 14 uhr entweder 16
kilometer marschieren mit dem 20 kilo
rucksack übrig alternativ 3,2 kilometer
schwimmen oder drei stunden tauchen
anschließend wieder die auslösung per
schiff machen und wieder ins netz 17 und
30 is feierabend allerdings muss man
auch trotzdem natürlich da die
mahlzeiten einhalten der allerletzte
snack ist und 22 uhr und dann will man
wahrscheinlich auch schon ins bett
fallen ernährung ist ungefähr so wie man
es auch von kraftsport kennt also viel
eiweiß wie kohlenhydrate möglichst
keinen zucker und möglichst keine
schnellen kohlenhydrate eiweiß wie zum
beispiel habe hier zum beispiel der
pizza ohne fleisch ist gar kein
absolutes no-go und scheinbar auch drin
und diesen tagesablauf werde ich ab
morgen durchziehen am tag vor dem
experiment gelten diese regeln aber noch
nichts da noch arbeit zu erledigen war
ging ich also erst 0 30 ins bett und
wachen nun fünf uhr morgens mit 4,5
stunden schlaf auf
vor dem sport halte ich meine
nahrungsaufnahme minimal ein bisschen
abgesagten portion ashley greenes einer
kapsel mit omega-3-fettsäuren und ein
paar reiswaffeln so habe ich zumindest
etwas energie bin aber trotzdem nicht zu
voll fürs training das mich gleich
erwartet 275 der drei 1500 kilokalorien
die täglich erreicht werden müssen sind
also schon mal geschafft
ja gesagt hallo eine frage kann man bei
euch ein probetraining heute machen ja
das ok haben die schwimmbäder bei euch
offen
ich freue mich ja schon ein bisschen
dass ich jetzt noch nicht irgendwie
eiskalte in serie muss aber ich glaube
es kommt noch die ausrüstung ist fertig
aufwendungen für fünf minuten zu spät
zum training nicht glaubt wenn ich ne
wie sie wäre gäbe es irgendjemanden der
super sauer wäre deswegen muss ich das
auf jeden fall genug kriegen
los geht's mit der ersten disziplin des
navy seals fitness-tests schwimmen als
absolute mindestvoraussetzung müssen
hier 500 jahres also circa 450 meter in
unter zwölf minuten 30 zurückgelegt
werden ich schaffe es mit ach und krach
als jemand der so gut wie nie schwimmt
sogar in zehn minuten 26 um nicht nur zu
bestehen sondern wirklich eine echte
chance gegen die konkurrenz zu haben
bräuchte man hier jedoch sogar acht
minuten
die nächste disziplin sind liegestütze
voraussetzungen sind 50 aber 80 bis 100
braucht man wenn man ernst genommen
werden möchte ich schaffe direkt nach
dem schwimmtraining nur 19 das könnte
lustig werden dritte disziplin sit-ups
brücken zum boden und ellbogen zu den
knien start der vorausgesetzten 50
schaffe ich nur 26 viertens klimmzüge
vorausgesetzt sind sehen ich schaffe 80
übergeht mich fast muss jetzt noch
laufen weil ich eigentlich bin auf dem
laufband machen zeigt ist allerdings
nicht also laufen einmal nach hause und
doch da die zeit also los geht's
fünftens anderthalb meilen also 24
kilometer laufen in unter 10 minuten 30
ich brauche dafür 16 minuten 25
wir werden sehen was sich da innerhalb
von nur einer woche machen lässt
ich will einfach aufgeben ich will
einfach recht auf wirst du üben h im
anschluss an das training gibt es direkt
frühstück dass man wenn man viel sport
macht auch die ganze zeit essen muss
weil sie jeder aber eine der meist
unterschätzten jedoch wichtigsten
aufgaben eines navy seals und generelle
militär ist es auch stets ordnung zu
halten
das klingt banal und oft denkt man dabei
ist reine schikane der vorgesetzten mit
dem finger probe nach staub zu suchen
doch im ernstfall ist ordnung
überlebenswichtig um sofort alles
essentielle griffbereit zu haben
aufzuräumen kommt in meinem normalen
alltag leider meistens zu kurz deshalb
kann ich hier viel lernen alles was ich
benutze wird anschließend fein
säuberlich gefaltet aufgehängt und kommt
an seinen platz und genauso hand habe
ich es auch mit der ausrüstung die bei
mir in meiner arbeit zum einsatz kommt
nachdem die anstrengungen des morgens
kalt abgeduscht wurde und auch die
frisur wieder an ihrem platz ist stehen
auf dem tagesplan eines navy seals
unterricht bzw unterweisung arbeiten an
der ausrüstung und sonstiges ich werde
in dieser zeit also auch einfach meinen
job nachgehen viele navy seals je nach
abteilung und einsatzgebiete machen
schließlich natürlich auch bürojobs und
papierkram auch wenn man in den film und
dokus natürlich nur die action zu
gesicht bekommt 11 uhr zwischenmahlzeit
noch mehr reiswaffeln nur um zwei
stunden danach schon wieder zu essen
sowohl für die mahlzeit ich habe normal
hunger
[Musik]
und nicht ich war jetzt nach dem essen
geht es eigentlich direkt zum
marschieren wenn euch ein bisschen raus
in den wald fahren und zwar muss das
auch einen gewissen tempo geschehen wenn
ich den ganzen tag zeit deswegen erstmal
die schenkung
245 pence wollen wir dass ich damit
nehmen das ist einfach normal der hier
liegt auf jeden fall schon mal ein kilo
und da muss er jetzt noch beschwert
werden das ding hier sind schon mal 30
points also 15 kilo es ist auch dabei
ganz wichtig 38 39 40 pence und dann
noch meine kamera die kommt auch mit die
liegt auch zu einer kilo also 5 pence
und dann haben wir 45 bei uns einfach an
ausrüstung dabei jungen das ist ja
normal
entspannt auf jeden fall daher muss ich
jetzt 16 kilometer lang marschieren auf
geht's
eingeplant sind hier für zweieinhalb
stunden und in dieser zeit ganze 16
kilometer im gehen zurück zu legen mit
einem gefühlten elefanten auf dem rücken
scheint für mich unmöglich aber ich gebe
mein bestes in den ersten zehn minuten
denke ich mir das ist für sie schwer ich
mache das jetzt ein paar meter und dann
gebe ich ihm auch nach 30 minuten bin
ich überrascht dass ich immer noch nicht
umgekippt bin nach einer stunde hat mein
gehirn aufgegeben widerstand zu leisten
und eingesehen dass ich das jetzt
wirklich durchziehen und nach
zweieinhalb stunden war ich fertig 12
eineinhalb kilometer mit 22 kilogramm
rucksack woher um alles in der welt die
fehlenden dreieinhalb kilometer nun
kommen sollen um die 16 voll zu machen
dass bis mir ein rätsel danach wird erst
mal gegessen und anschließend hat selbst
ein navy seal außerhalb eines seltenen
einsatzes feierabend ich bin so fertig
ich kann mich gar nicht erzählt er ich
bin es ist jetzt 22 45 kessels bleibt
diesmal ein bisschen mehr schlaf
überragt 2 genau das gleiche hier
nochmal nur heute steht anstatt 16
kilometer marsch 2,4 kilometer schwimmen
an ich fahre also raus zum fühlinger see
in chorweiler der zufällig ein fast
exakt 24 kilometer langer see in
perfekter swimmingpool form ist wie für
mich gemacht
aber
max nix
[Musik]
ich starte hier an diesem ende und
schwimme dann unter einer brücke durch
dann unter einer zweiten hindurch die
brücke die ihr hier seht ist übrigens
diese keine brücke nur damit ihr mal ein
gefühl für die distanz bekommt für die
ich übrigens ganze eine stunde und 25
minuten brauchte weil ich mich häufig
auf den rücken legen und ausruhen musste
über einen weg geht es dann unterkühlt
einmal um den see zu fuß zurück zum auto
[Musik]
ich glaube das dümmste was ich jemals
gemacht habe
ich sag's euch wie es ist ich bin
komplett auf mich warten ungefähr sechs
stunden schlaf aber wenigstens die habe
ich mir jetzt verdammt haben wir
verdient vorher steht und ein halt
[Musik]
ach ich hab heute kaum gefilmt der navy
seals zeitplan ist extrakt genommen wenn
ich dann noch immer kameras auf und
wieder abbauen muss ein auto ist kaum
hin alle sache nicht übrigen ist das
mein schlaf rhythmus nicht auf zack ist
daran habe ich recht so lange gearbeitet
ohne irgendwelche resultate ende letzten
jahres habe ich das mal einen monat lang
exakt getrackt mit durchschnittlich ins
bett gegangen bin ich da um 5 und
aufgestanden um 11 und jetzt gehe ich um
11 ins bett und stehen
so ich bin diesmal ich muss auch schnell
sein muss 16 km maschinen zweieinhalb
stunden sind dass wir dann anstrengend
ich jetzt meine kamera herunter weil die
ist schwer
ich kann versteht so groß wie ich kann
alles zu denen es knallhart wirklich und
ich habe erst eineinhalb kilometer
wenn ich jetzt diesen schnürsenkel
binden das hab ich die zeit nicht ich
bin immer noch zehn sekunden pro minute
ich weiß nicht wie gegen den mann
ergehen kann hatte ich auch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weltweit für uns behalten aber in foren
dass sobald
ich hoffe die treppen hoch ich habe mega
geblasen nicht mehr nur den fersen
sondern auch in den fußsohlen ich weiß
nicht mal dass es geht ich weiß nicht
was überwiegt das gute gefühl das ich
durchgezogen habe oder motto schmerz
definitiv der schmerz geschrien habe ich
marschiert auch und das zur genüge was
fehlt ist ein tauchgang denn ein navy
seal aber natürlich auch dieser ziel
hier ist ein experte unter wasser ich
hingegen hat noch nie mit
sauerstoffflasche getaucht und das
werden wir heute ändern das tauchbecken
der tauchschule dich aufgesucht habe
sieht etwa so aus wie man sich atlantis
vorstellt und geht auf 37 und hier sogar
bis auf 20 meter tiefe mal schauen wie
weit ich komme
krebs kommt der artega dran und somit
hast du das zum ersten mal seien 1000
kinder zusammen gebaut ich bin das
einmal gleich zum alle erstmal eine
sauerstoffflasche tauchen ich will zum
allerersten mal irgendwie knapp zehn
meter tauchen oder mehr und vor allem
gleich auch zum allerersten mal aus
einer sauerstoffflasche atmen aber
[Musik]
jetzt geht's los ich werde eingewiesen
in das tauchen und lernen wie man sein
equipment vorbereite das atmen durch die
flasche fühlt sich komisch an aber nicht
weil es sich wirklich komisch anfühlt
sondern weil es sich über wasser so
normal anfühlt dass ich jetzt fast
gruselig finde unter wasser blubbert
dann aber natürlich beim ausatmen luft
nach oben die zeichensprache der taucher
im einsatz zu sehen ist faszinierend es
gibt einige feste internationale zeichen
aber manchmal muss man auch
improvisieren wie hier zum beispiel als
ich meinen tauchlehrer schrägstrich
kameramann zu verstehen geben dass ich
gerne von hinten gefilmt werden würde
[Musik]
doch plötzlich bei 5 meter tiefe und
entsprechendem druck ein stechender
schmerz in meinem rechten auge wir
brechen ab und damit ist ausgeschlossen
dass wir noch tiefer gehen werden ich
gebe zwar für diese videos mein bestes
und nehme dafür einiges an schmerzen in
kauf aber hier ist definitiv eine grenze
erreicht dr google sagt hinterher es war
ein so genanntes barotrauma der
tauchlehrer verschreibt mir einen arzt
besuchen das stechen verschwand wieder
sobald ich an der oberfläche war aber
abends beim essen kehrt es noch einmal
leicht zurück es wird sich zeigen was
genau bei mir in den augen oder im kopf
verkehrt ist und hoffentlich lässt es
sich beheben ansonsten werde ich niemals
in meinem leben tiefer als fünf meter
tauchen können was ich als schweren
schlag empfinden würde wirklich nervös
werden könnte ich damit also schon gar
nicht heute ist freitag und damit stellt
sich mir eine dringende frage haben navy
seals eigentlich wochenende versuchen
aber eigentlich fand ich schon gar nicht
jeden tag so zu quälen und so weit zu
gehen das andere hat er so sagen würden
hey das ist voll dumm es war wirklich
total und trotzdem was wahrscheinlich
nur ein bruchteil von dem was ein echter
name ist hier so durchmachen muss für
mich als aber definitiv gereicht ein
strafmaß werde beibehalten jetzt
vielleicht nicht um fünf aufstehen aber
um sechs hatte ich habe eigentlich noch
interessanter finde ist wie geil es sich
anfühlt einfach direkt nach dem man
irgendwas macht hinterher andere
aufzuräumen ich persönlich habe das noch
nie ein rezept durchgezogen im leben und
das gefühl danach einfach durch ist wird
sich entspannt morgen der fitnesstest
die 450 meter schwimmen schaffe ich
diesmal in neun minuten 55 also 30
sekunden schneller als beim letzten mal
wieder bestanden bei den liegestützen
aber merkt man dass sich durch den
pausenlosen sport wirklich verausgabt
bin ich schaffe also nur 16 statt 19 und
bin wieder durchgefallen und bei den sit
ups zeigt sich direkt das gleiche muster
nur 23 statt ursprünglich 26 und auch
hier wieder durchgefallen weiter geht es
mit klimmzügen hier schaffe ich immerhin
wieder acht wie beim letzten mal
trotzdem wieder durchgefallen und jetzt
war alles aus schwimmen der komplett mit
dem laufen
[Musik]
13 minuten 59
ich hab es ist amtlich navy seal werde
ich in den dafür hat sie überhaupt gar
nicht gereicht aber immerhin beim laufen
zweieinhalb minuten schneller geworden
wenn ich was gelernt habe diese woche
dann ist das alles zu geben und hey
immerhin habe ich es überlebt teil
meiner morgen routine ist übrigens mein
täglicher e-tron drink und der auch in
dieser knallharten woche wichtige
energie gegeben yuan von athletic kriens
teams wollen wir des heutigen videos ist
ein pulver aus 75 komplett natürlichen
inhaltsstoffen zum beispiel aus echten
pilzen echt wurzeln echten früchten und
gräsern die alle vitamine mineralstoffe
und antioxidantien liefern wie man mit
seinen normalen mahlzeiten kaum alle
abdeckt wie zum beispiel perfekt
aufeinander abgestimmte ps komplexe die
die verdauung nährstoffaufnahme und das
immunsystem stärken können sowie
vitamine und mineralstoffe welche für
ein funktionieren das nervensystem
wichtig sind das hier ist das
willkommens kette samt edelstahl dose
für das pulver shaker und löffeln dann
einfach einen löffel aus der edelstahl
dose zusammen mit wasser in der
mitgelieferten flasche mischen und
fertig ich persönlich mache jeden tag
direkt aufstehen und ein starker
nebeneffekt die nicht direkt gemerkt
habe ist dass ich natürlich automatisch
ordentlich mit dritten morgens und auch
dass diese eine erste gewohnheit direkt
motivation gibt es mit der nächsten
durchzustarten klingt jetzt auf athletic
greens punkt com / tommy und pin teure
morgen putin an jedem mal der zuschauer
wird zu der bestellung einen
jahresvorrat an vitamin b2 und k2 sowie
fünf praktischen travelex kostenlos dazu
gelegt und wenn ihr nicht happy sound
gibt es ein 60 tage geld-zurück-garantie